bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur ce live
à une semaine de la fin du mercato on va
faire un petit point pour avoir toute
l'actualité des transferts du football
je suis aujourd'hui avec sébastien
terrasse et sébastien salut dans un sens
ça va bien ça bien ouais et bien voilà
nous allons partir sûr on va vous
discuté d'abord une petite heure vous
n'hésitez pas dans les commentaires à
nous poser vos questions sur le mercato
sébastien y répondra on a déjà quelques
unes sur justement ronaldo on y verra un
peu plus tard d'abord on va commencer
par là le gros dossier on va dire de
ceux de ce mercato du jour et peut-être
de la fin du mercato c'est le dossier
qui viennent m bape et ouais je sais
qu'il aime d'apc celui qui rajoute qui a
agité un peu tout le feuilleton du
mercato en france en tout cas avec le
psg le real madrid qui le courtisent mal
depuis depuis même qu'il était à monaco
depuis des années il hier on a appris
que bp aurait fait l'objet d'une offre
du real madrid d'environ 160 180
millions d'euros
maintenant c'est son pdg de décider ce
qui va faire de me taper égal surtout la
sortie aujourd'hui médiatique de
leonardo leonardo qui a dit en gros on
est ok pour le vendre mais ce sera à nos
conditions donc 60 millions ce sera pas
suffisant ils vont le vendre plus cher
voilà alors leonardo il dit un petit peu
tout et son contraire il essaie surtout
de rejeter la pression sur le sur le
real madrid en disant que le psg a
plutôt de contrôle alors le psg ce qu'il
a vraiment contrôler ce qui peut
vraiment faire un peu ce qu'il veut avec
bape est ce qu a dit surtout leonardo et
ce qui était très intéressant c'est
qu'il a dit qu' apparemment me battais
veut partir il n'a pas dit que ma paire
demander son départ du psg mais il a dit
je crois que c'est exact c'était sa part
est clair qu apparemment bape et donc
veut bien quitter le psg que c'est son
souhait leonardo a réaffirmé le soin du
psg de le prolonger aujourd'hui ça
semble impossible effectivement à quoi
on peut s'attendre dans les jours à
venir à une espèce de d'intox entre les
deux part entre les trois parties en
finale parce qu'il ya le real madrid
d'un côté il ya le psg il ya aussi qu'il
ya là une map et à quoi on peut
s'attendre c'est sur ces futurs jour sur
les prochains jours c'est très difficile
à dire en tout cas ce qu'on peut
constater c'est qu'aujourd'hui les trois
parties joue cartes sur table en tout
cas sur le long terme le real madrid
s'est clairement savoir qu'il veut qu'il
ya maps et il ne se cache plus le psg
reconnaît que qu'il aime bape et veut
s'en aller
et qui à me taper s'il ne communique pas
son silence aussi est éloquent c'est
clair qu'il veut quitter le pays ou
régions aujourd'hui qui veut jouer au
real madrid maintenant sur les prochains
jours c'est très difficile de savoir ce
qui va se passer parce que toutes les
solutions sont possibles va p peut
rester sans prolonger le psg peut
décider de ne pas le vendre s'il trouve
que l'offre n'est pas suffisante et
aussi joué un peu ce ce tour de force en
disant non on ne va pas céder comme ça
on va pas c'est le pg qui décide c'est
pas qu'ils aient la paix ce n'est pas le
real madrid
maintenant est-ce que le psg peut
s'asseoir sur 160 180 millions d'euros
comme ça sur une indemnité de transfert
ça c'est très difficile à dire c'est
aujourd'hui on peut absolument pas le
dire surtout que le c'est très risqué
parce que dans un an qu'il aime ep sera
libre dans 560 millions c'est énorme
comme offre à un an de la fin du contrat
d'un joueur oui c'est énorme c'est
absolument énorme d'autant plus que dans
la crise actuelle on se rappelle que le
fair-play financier a été énormément
allégé donc l' équilibre financier en
termes d'achats de ventes il ya un petit
peu moins important mais il est quand
même important pour même pour le psg
pour le psg qu'il ya énormément d'argent
et qui peut se permettre de d'injecter
autant d'argent qu'il le veut même pour
eux c'est important pour équilibrer les
comptes auprès des différentes instances
on se rappelle que la dncg le gendarme
financier du football français s'est vu
promettre par le psg que le club allait
ventes pour 181 millions d'euros
aujourd'hui pg on est extrêmement loin
je crois qu'il a que mitchell baker qui
est parti pour quelque chose comme 7
millions d'euros forcément au départ de
me taper ça réglerait tous ces problèmes
là ça arrangerait le psg peut-être sur
certains aspects financiers ça
permettrait peut-être aussi de renforcer
le club de renforcer l'équipe pardon à
d'autres postes à d'autres postes
peut-être plus importante le priorité
aujourd'hui est ce que l'attaquant du
psg peut survivre au départ de deux maps
et on peut penser que oui avec neymar
lionel messi entre elles di maria il ya
pas mal de demandes pour faire une
attaque cohérente alors qu'il ya des
postes peut-être où c'est un peu plus
discutable poste de latéral gauche au
milieu de terrain donc le psg
aujourd'hui peut peut conserver mbappé
mais sa part être un choix c'est assez
surprenant et est un choix que le psg
pourrait être aidé pour prendre un pari
est ce que au 1er septembre mba paix à
ton avis sera dans l'effectif du paris
saint germain ou pas
pense qu'il sera pas dans l'effectif du
paris saint germain je le pense mais
c'est vraiment on en sait vraiment rien
aujourd'hui c'est impossible de faire
une prédiction parce que même les
déclarations de leonardo ne veulent pas
dire grand chose en tout cas ils
n'affirment pas de maps et va rester ou
va partir mais ça paraît assez fou de se
dire que le psg va accepter de voir
mbappé s'en aller librement surtout que
s'il reste n'a aucun espoir qui prolonge
au aucun espoir honnêtement je pense que
on sait jamais ce qui peut se passer
dans une saison mais ça n'a tellement
pas avancé ces derniers mois que ça
paraît difficilement imaginable que bape
et se disent tant pis je laisse tomber
le real madrid j'ai plus envie d'y aller
je veux bien rester au psg très bien on
avait pas mal de questions alors c'est
celle de tik tok et d'une autre personne
que je n'ai plus le sol sous la main qui
nous demandait est-ce que
ronaldo du coup pourrait arriver au psg
et si une vache au pelage est d'abord
quelqu'un pourrait-il aller on a le dos
et une information aussi de l'équipe qui
avait dit que cristiano ronaldo voulait
aller à manchester city alors est-ce que
ronaldo veut quitter la juventus
aujourd'hui là aussi beaucoup
d'informations vont dans ce sens là
apparemment il veut partir mais ce qu'il
peut aller au psg évidemment s'il va si
ça devait se faire ça ne se ferait pas
sans un départ de clients de ba paix
maintenant est ce que c'est un choix
cohérent pour p&g ça paraît
pas vraiment pas vraiment cohérent en
tout cas un joueur qui a déjà 36 ans de
le faire jouer avec messi neymar est ce
que ça va pas un peu se marcher sur les
pieds financièrement le psg récupère un
dossier très compliqué parce que c'est
ça aussi le gros problème de la juventus
si la juventus ne veut plus vraiment de
ronaldo c'est parce que financièrement
il est très difficile à assumer malgré
son apport sportif qui est encore bon
est ce que ronaldo peut signer au psg ça
ressemblerait un peu un caprice du psg
de se dire on perd mbappé ben on va
refaire un autre gros coup on va ramener
une autre star on va réunir messi et
ronaldo et neymar en plus
c'est incroyable comme en termes
d'impact d'avoir ces trois joueurs là
exactement maintenant est-ce que ronaldo
aurait vraiment sa place à manchester
city est ce que ça ferait sens de le
voir partir à manchester city on
rappelle que c'est une icône à moins
qu'ils aient un héritage qu'il a écrit
ça sa légende notamment là bas que ça
ferait sûrement très mal au coeur aux
supporters de united de le voir à city
que ronaldo a city sous pep guardiola
qui a toujours été son ennemi qu a
toujours été à l'autre entre la base et
le barça bien sûr qu a toujours été un
coach un peu aux antipodes du jeu
ronaldo ça paraît difficilement
concevable aujourd'hui c'est difficile
de trouver une porte de sortie à ronaldo
hors de la juventus ça manque de après
effectivement il faut contre où il va il
faut qu'il trouve dès que des clubs qui
ont les reins solides et au final seuls
city et paris peuvent lui offrir sa à
l'heure actuelle a priori seul city et
paris peuvent lui offrir c'est
l'impression qu'ils donnent en tout cas
dans les grands clubs européens
évidemment on va pas sortir du continent
européen parce que ça n'a pas du tout
l'air d'être le projet de naldo
maintenant ronaldo il a encore une année
de contrat à la juventus il peut tout à
fait rester l'honorer et puis voilà mais
là aussi sportivement la juventus a
quand même un peu baissé d'un cran
l'élimination en huitièmes de finale de
la ligue des champions ça a été vécu
comme une humiliation là bas ça
d'ailleurs coûté son poste à andrea
pirlo qui venait à peine d'arriver qui
était érigée comme comme le renouveau un
peu à la juventus
ronaldo c'est difficile de prédire son
avenir il va quand même l'air vraiment
coincé à la juventus aujourd'hui très
bien n'hésitez pas à continuer à poser
vos questions on essaiera d'y répondre
on va essayer de faire un peu à un tour
de toute l'actualité du mercato de cette
dernière semaine en tout cas il ya un
gros dossier en france aussi qu'on
attend on attend un dénouement c'est
celui d'eduardo canal inga le grand
prodige du foot français qui sort d'une
saison un peu en demi teinte on peut
dire
qu est ce qui peut se passer pour lui
sur cette dernière semaine sachant qu'il
joue toujours à rennes exactement alors
que mavinga on le rappelle c'est un peu
comme ronaldo comme bab et pour le coup
il ya en fin de contrat en juin prochain
donc le stade rennais est un peu obligé
de prendre une décision ça fait des mois
que là aussi rennes veut prolonger son
joueur que les n'y arrive pas et qu'
apparemment ça ne prendra pas du tout la
direction maintenant la décision c est
ce qu il reste et il part libre ou est
ce qu'on le vend maintenant et on
empêche de l'argent sur ce joueur formé
au club
c'est ouest-france qui disait que
cabinda avait confié qu'il avait joué
son dernier match à rennes le week-end
dernier l'équipe a dit que pas forcément
donc les informations ou un peu dans
tous les sens et a priori rennes
redoutent redoutent rentrée 10 mai une
offensive d'un club au dernier moment
dans le mercato peut-être le 30 31 août
et donc se retrouver dos au mur et être
un peu obligé de vendre qu'à mavinga
peut-être pour un prix un peu plus
faible que sa valeur un peu comme comme
bape et ronaldo qui sont en fin de
contrat comme tous ces joueurs en fin de
contrat qui qui ont leur valeur
forcément qui baisse a priori le psg est
toujours très très chaud sur le dossier
k mavinga et pense pouvoir faire un bon
coup à un prix le prix qui tourne c'est
30 millions d'euros pour 15mhz having a
pour le potentiel qui a démontré c'est
quand même très intéressant chelsea et
manchester united sont aussi annoncés
shoah c'est à ses chaussures sur ce
dossier a priori qu'un mavinga ça va
être difficile de le revoir à rennes
après trente et un autres on se rappelle
que quand même l'an dernier à l'été
dernier on estimer on en parlait de
somme de 100 millions d et là on a
l'impression que sa cote a énormément
baissé c'est aussi parce que c'est la
fin de son contrat non tout à fait il ya
plein de facteurs il ya sa fin de
contrat dans un an il ya sa dernière
saison qui était un petit peu décevante
qui laissent penser qu' on s'est
peut-être un petit peu emballé sur le
potentiel de quais mavinga qui arrive
est très très fort dans le milieu
professionnel qui au bout de ne même pas
30 matchs et est international français
qu'on en parlait déjà au real madrid
donc forcément des sommes assez folles
sont arrivés mais aussi toute la crise
qui fait que les prix peuvent un petit
peu baissé et que rennes n'est peut-être
pas tant que ça en position de force
dans ce dossier donc si jamais le prix
de came having a doit baisser rennes
devra juste s'y résoudre il essaie ça
parce qu'elle est quelque chose d'assez
global c'est qu'il est tous les clubs
ont quand même un peu besoin de vendre à
ce mercato et ne l'ont pas encore tous
trophée en tout cas oui tout à fait
l'exemple du psg c'est sûrement le plus
frappant qui devait le vendre par moreau
et cardy qui est annoncé sur le départ
qui est finalement joutant que messi et
neymar ne sont pas là ils qui marqua
quasiment tous les matches sarah bien
aussi au psg qui devait partir alphonse
areola qui a fini par trouver une porte
de sortie mais c'est vrai qu'il ya pas
mal de joueurs qui ont un peu du mal à à
partir à être vendus c'est aussi un peu
le serpent qui se mord la queue
finalement c'est que les clubs n'ont pas
forcément les moyens d'acheter et donc
quand ils veulent vendre bas ils tombent
sur les clubs qui n'ont pas les moyens
d'acheter donc c'est forcément difficile
de l'enclencher beaucoup de mouvements
mais parce que jusque là c'était
l'angleterre qui permettait d'acheter en
gros les les joueurs en mettant des
grosses sommes c'est plus autant de cas
qu'avant on va dire c'est plus autant
qu'à et puis on voit aussi que les
transferts anglo anglais sont de plus en
plus commun avec des sommes justement à
ce moment là qui explose un petit peu on
l'avait avec jack goualich par exemple
qui a quitté aston villa pour manchester
city pour plus de 100 millions d'euros
on pouvait le voir on ne verra sûrement
pas finalement les caries kane qui était
très courtisé par manchester city là
aussi avec des sommes qui tournait
autour de 130 140 millions d'euros
effectivement le mercato le mercato
anglais en tout cas le football anglais
généralement les moyens d'injecter
beaucoup d'argent chez les autres q
justement on parle d' harry caine harry
caine qui était le kéké le grand
attaquant de tottenham lors j'ai pu les
stades sous les yeux mais en terme de
buts marqués c'est absolument ahurissant
ce qu'il a réussi ces dernières années
il était annoncé sur le départ depuis
très longtemps il devait on pensait
qu'ils allaient partir on était assez
sûr de ça et au final il va rester à
tottenham c'est ça c'est ce qu'il a
annoncé aujourd'hui qu'il restait à
tottenham qu'il était 100% concentré sur
tottenham alors c'est une annonce très
forte parce que la presse anglaise le
matin même parlé d'une dernière
offensive de manchester city dans le
dossier harry caine donc c'est un
message très fort de la part d' harry
caine parce que on le rappelle il ya
tout un feuilleton harry caine qui qui
supposément avait séché l'entraînement
qui manifestaient vraiment son envie de
de partir de tottenham on rappelle que
c'est un joueur formé au club qu'il a
aujourd'hui 28 ans et il met buts sur
buts chaque saison qui tourne à 20 25
buts par saison en 1re ligue c'est une
moyenne vraiment très impressionnant
c'est le capitaine de l'angleterre c'est
l'un des meilleurs attaquants au monde
tout simplement et à tottenham il n'a
rien gagné à 28 ans il n'a aucun trophée
aujourd'hui le club a presque régresser
il ne joue même plus la ligue europa et
je vous la ligue europa conférence qui
est un peu l'équivalent de la coupe
intertoto pour ceux qui se souviennent à
l'époque ce qui effectivement c'est pas
très glorieux et finalement avec kane a
l'air de jurer fidélité à tottenham
c'est peut-être aussi le président
tottenham on l'appelle daniel levy qui
est vraiment un homme de poigne qui a
dit clairement hors de question de
toucher à riquet et donc effectivement
il pourrait rester à wigan qui jusqu'au
bout comme tu l'as dit il n'a toujours
pas gagné trophée il voulait peut-être
arrivé à aller dans un grand club comme
l'ont fait
gareth bale avant pour aller à madrid
modric qui avait fait pareil faut aller
à madrid fera peut-être qu'il y ait la
paix comme le fait qu'il ya des grands
clubs pourtant mai mais effectivement il
vit il avait cette volonté de partir est
ce que justement le fait que harry caine
ne partent pas à moins de sorties ça
peut être une raison de plus pour
ronaldo d'arriver à city ou pas
effectivement maintenant le dossier
harry caine semble semble au point mort
en tout cas ça serait une énorme
surprise que harry caine s'en aille
après qu'il ait dit je reste à tottenham
noir sur blanc
effectivement les il ya des dossiers
this ferme donc il y en a d'autres qui
restent ouverts et qui peuvent du coup
se décanter si jamais qu'il ya un bape
et signe au real madrid là aussi ça peut
ouvrir donc la porte à ronaldo au psg
effectivement ronaldo il peut se
retrouver un petit peu le dernier dans
ses très très très très grand joueur à
vouloir partir maintenant est ce qu'un
club va se dire d'accord je prends
ronaldo je prends tout son salaire tout
ce qu'il englobe financièrement
sportivement la place qu'il doit prendre
dans l' équilibre dans le jeu il faut
qu'il soit il faut qu'il soit titulaire
faut qu'il soit titulaire il faut que le
que l'équipe s'adapte peut-être un petit
peu à lui est ce que ronaldo peut
s'intégrer parfaitement au jeu de pep
guardiola est ce que ça pourrait marcher
à moins de leicester city c'est pas
certain et la question aussi se poserait
au psg est ce que lionel messi cristiano
ronaldo et cie serait si orelsan je peux
jouer ensemble personnellement j'ai
envie de le penser parce que ce sont
deux grands joueurs qui seraient
cohabiter mais c'est forcément c'est pas
juste on récupère ronaldo un super
joueur s'il ya beaucoup de choses qui
sont engendrées derrière on est une
question de principe avoir une question
c'est plus une remarque de mohamed bacar
hamada qui nous dit les dirigeants du
psg agissent comme des footix alors tu
sais pas si c'est le fait d'essayer de
rassembler toutes ces stars ou de
laisser partir m bape et on peut quand
même rappeler le mercato réussi par par
paris jusque là qui était quand même un
sans faute oui un sans faute et
notamment ce qu'on a beaucoup louent et
c'est que les joueurs arrivent et sont
exceptionnels et que la plupart viennent
libre alors certes il ya toujours une
commission de l'agent un salaire tout ça
quand même un coût mais ce sont quand
même de vrais cours réalisés par par le
psg m'a parlé de donna roumat le joueur
qui a été élu car gardien qui a été élu
meilleur joueur de l'euro 2020 c'est
quand même très très fort sergio ramos
qui a fait toute sa carrière au real
madrid dans toute sa carrière mais
toutes ces légendes au real madrid
mais si on va même pas en parler là on
les voit très bien très bien en photo
c'est un mercato exceptionnel maintenant
c'est vrai qu'il ya un côté un peu jeu
vidéo dans ce set capacité à avoir réuni
autant de stars et surtout des joueurs
je pense surtout à ramos et missy qu'on
imaginait jamais quitté respectivement
le real madrid et le barça s'est aidé de
la roma aussi qui était au milan depuis
très longtemps alors ses terres c'est un
jeune joueur mais effectivement c'était
un peu c'est un peu une icône ils ont
réussi à récupérer tous ces joueurs là
et les rassembler on a aussi sur la cr z
photo ashraf à kimi et giardino wild
adoum jamais attrait dernière son prénom
mais qui vont pas qu'ils nous montrent
que sarko demain 10 l effectivement
après le départ de maps et pourrait un
peu disons porter un peu atteinte à
cette asbl cateau parfait on va dire
mais ça restera quand même du très bon
cru oui tout à fait sûr sur le
recrutement en tout cas c'est
extrêmement fort ce cas c'est ce qu'a
fait le psg maintenant il faudra
peut-être accepter quelques quelques
concessions surtout que kiel un bape et
s'il ne s'en va pas cet été principe il
partira l'année prochaine en tout cas on
l'a dit une prolongation de contrat ça
me semble plus du tout à l'ordre du jour
même leonardo l'a un peu avoué à demi
mot même s'il vit qu'au psg veut
toujours prolonger mais pour qui un tel
retournement de situation il faudrait
vraiment qu'il se passe des choses
incroyables durant la saison au psg
bat b semble voué à partir alors il vaut
peut-être mieux qui partant le temps cet
été il certes le mercato parisien tmx 21
sera un petit peu moins jolie on se dira
à cette ombre au tableau mais en même
temps est-ce que le psg regrettera qu'il
y ait un bape et sportivement
toute façon si les voit partir il vaut
peut-être mieux qu'ils partent
maintenant quoi c'est sûr comme on le
disait pour l'épauler buteur d'indemnité
de transfert c'est aussi beaucoup plus
intéressant pour le psg de laisser
partir maintenant plutôt que de le
laisser partir libre dans un an on va
continuer un petit un petit tour des
stades un petit tour des stades un petit
tour des clubs en tout cas en france
avec nice est une possibilité de
l'arrivée d'andy delort l'attaquant
montpelliérain on a vu des images fortes
ce week end
de l'attaquant qui devraient normalement
quitter montpellier
bientôt à la fin de la semaine ouais
tout à fait le week-end dernier on l'a
vu avec montpellier il a quitté le
terrain en quasiment larmes lorsqu'il
est lorsqu'il est sorti en cours de
match
on peut comprendre que c'est sûrement
son dernier match à montpellier sauf
sauf si le dossier n'est pas réglée ce
week end ou qu'il ya un gros couac mais
a priori montpellier a accepté une offre
de 10 millions d'euros de la part de
l'ogcnice pour le départ d'andy delort
andy delort il a fait une excellente
saison je crois quelque chose comme 16
buts 9 passes décisives en ligue 1 il a
formé un duo exceptionnel avec gaëtan
laborde qui semblait plutôt être celui
des deux qui allait partir et finalement
ça s'est joué un peu au dernier moment
d'ailleurs montpellier un petit peu
pesté en verre l'ogcnice ans en
regrettant que koné dit que les
dirigeants que christophe galtier
notamment nauges pas vraiment cartes sur
table sur leur intérêt pour andy delort
ils sont obligés un peu de laisser
partir en fin de mercato on rappelle
encore une fois qui fait partie de ces
joueurs en fin de contrat donc là aussi
montanier était un petit peu d'eau mur
avec un joueur qui avait envie de
rejoindre ce projet très ambitieux de
logistique on a aussi évoqué un intérêt
de marseille pour andy delort ça
pourrait après des soucis de ce week end
entre les deux clubs peut-être qu'ils
vont aussi se jouer sur ce sur ce
dossier là sachant qu'en plus du coup
montpellier pourrait perdre de l'or est
ce que gaëtan laborde devrait rester
est-ce qu'il partirait a priori on part
plus sur l'idée que gaëtan laborde va
rester pour montpellier là ça serait
extrêmement dur de perdre ses deux
attaquants stars les deux joueurs qu'il
portait vraiment l'attaquent quinon qui
seront très difficiles à remplacer voire
impossible à remplacer dans les derniers
jours du mercato a priori ces actes et
andy delort nationale et la destination
effectivement on verra l'olympique de
marseille est un peu revenu sur ce
dossier un peu au dernier moment pour
essayer de piéger l'ogcnice et en
profiter justement avec cet échange un
peu sulfureux entre nice et montpellier
peut-être qu'il y avait une opportunité
à faire pour l'instant de l'or est plus
proche quand même de l'ogcnice est a
priori gaëtan laborde va rester lui a
par contre à monter et on parle d'eux
de valère germain peut-être pour le pour
remplacer est ce que c'est quelque chose
dont on croit il faut quand même
rappeler marc germain qui a fêté très
bonne saison du côté de nice à une
époque où à monaco qui s'est
complètement perdus à marseille on peut
le dire oui c'est un petit peu perdues
il n'a pas supporté la concurrence il a
il a perdu fils ammar s'est clairement
maintenant ça serait effectivement une
alternative
bas beaucoup moins ambitieuse que andy
delort et gaëtan laborde qui eux restent
sur d'excellentes saisons alors que
valère germain ne souhaite plus du tout
à l'om qui l'a qu'il n'a pas été
prolongée parce que parce qu'il avait
clairement il était clairement arrivé au
bout de son histoire avec l'om qui
n'avait plus toute sa place
c'est difficile d'avoir beaucoup
d'ambition si on remplace andy delort
par valère germain avec tout le respect
qu'on peut avoir pour lui effectivement
ces belles saisons à nice monaco il a
montré qu'il était un attaquant faits
affirme de ligue 1 maintenant sur les
dernières impressions qu'il a laissé à
l'om effectivement ce n'est pas ce n'est
pas une ambition revue à la hausse pour
montpellier que de se séparer d'eux de
l'or et de le remplacer par vale jardin
rappelons qu effectivement benjamin est
en fin de contrat avec l'om et du coup
il a plus de club pendant tout l'été il
n'a toujours pas et ne peut toujours pas
trouvé de club on a des commentaires
alors on a pas mal de madrid n dans le
chat un qui nous dit à l'ats madrid un
bien sûr c'est qu'ils sont à mon avis
pour le fait que pour le fait que ceux
qui l aiment bapt et signale à madrid on
a l'impression
on peut continuer ce petit tour ce petit
tour des clubs de ligue 1 avec marseille
marseille qui acquiert qui a cafouillé
eu pas mal de changements ces derniers
jours raonic qui partait benfica lire
aulaqi qui revient ils ont enfin réussi
à faire revenir leur latéral est
d'amener le taux qui s'en va oui il ya
eu un marcato extrêmement vous mentez il
est beaucoup beaucoup d'arrivées je
crois qu'on est à quelque chose comme
huit ou neuf recrues bientôt en tout cas
surtout avec les derniers dossiers
qu'ils vont qui vont se régler donc
effectivement né manière anonyme qui est
parti à benfica en prêt avec option
d'achat qui l'option d'achat sera levé
si vous insérez un nombre de matchs
hanks pas sûr qu'il soit définitivement
parti de l'om mais voilà l'om essayez un
petit peu d'évincer ses joueurs
indésirables
et derrière le recrutement il et il est
très intéressant il ya déjà eu des
matteo renzi
conrad et la fuente thing is under et là
pour le coup paul gayraud là ça a été un
gros dossier pour lire là il a fait une
très bonne seconde partie de saison à
l'om ou unité seulement prêtés par la
fiorentina finalement ils ont réussi à
s'entendre il est de retour pour
l'instant l'om gère bien son mercato et
c'est plutôt ça va plutôt dans le bon
sens en tout cas sur les derniers jours
du mercato je vais demander à raphaël
qui ans qui en régie de nous mettre un
petit pour qu'on puisse voir voilà alors
nous ne vous raconte pas pour vous
montrer un peu à quoi ressemble
l'effectif de marseille alors ce n'est
pas l'ex de l'effectif exact bien
évidemment mais bon comme on le disait
voilà payet alors ça c'est à peu près
comment ils ont joué ce week-end sauf
que d'un joueur qu'on ne trouve pas sur
fifa donc du coup ils du coup nous
manque le personnes qui n'étaient pas là
effectivement mais payet les cénacles
guendouzi under guendouzi qui est aussi
une une bonne recrue on l'a vu sur ces
derniers matchs oui une recrue déjà très
ambitieuse c'est un joueur très coté
auparavant à arsenal il s'était vraiment
imposé après il a eu des des problèmes
de comportement avec son entraîneur
mikel arteta il s'est retrouvé un peu
exilé au hertha berlin où là aussi il a
quand même gardé un bon rythme c'était
le capitaine de l'équipe de france
espoirs si un jour avec beaucoup de
personnalité qu'avait été aussi convoqué
par didier deschamps chez les a et sur
ces premiers matchs à noël c'est très
intéressant on ressent beaucoup de
personnalité de verticalité dans son jeu
pour l'instant ça a tout d'une bonne
recrue pour l'om
n'hésitez pas à continuer à poser vos
questions on va essayer d'y répondre
avec ce qu'on sait effectivement on peut
passer peut-être un retour en ligue 1
c'est celui d'adil rami qui s'est engagé
un peu à la surprise générale voleurs
pour pour 3
adil rami qui sortait de quand même
depuis les changements du monde
énormément de saison difficile oui
c'était difficile ça fait partie de ces
champions du monde qui l'ont un peu mal
digéré le titre et qui n'ont pas su
forcément assumer derrière il était à
l'om à ce moment là on se rappelle et
ans lors de la saison 2018 2019 après la
coupe du monde en seconde partie de
saison il a complètement disparu il eu
des blessures il a quasiment plus joué
en fin de saison dernière il était en
fin de contrat ensuite si je me souviens
bien il est parti à fenerbahçe où il n'a
pas eu le temps de jeu on sait
absolument pas imposer à l'hiver au bout
de six mois il est parti à sotchi en
russie pour réussir en russie là où il
était champion du monde il va bien se
relancer il n'a pas joué un seul match
il s'est plaint de ne pas avoir été
payés ça a été un fiasco il a finalement
rebondi au portugal à boavista près de
près de porto donc à boavista en
première division portugaise là bas il a
fini par s'imposer il a même joué les
onze derniers matches en intégralité
donc il a retrouvé du rythme aujourd'hui
adil rami il est plutôt bien
physiquement en tout cas il arrive à
enchaîner les matches donc c'est très
intéressant pour pour trois dans la dans
l'optique du maintien d'avoir un joueur
comme ça d'expérience qui a un vécu qui
est capable au moins d'enchaîner les
matchs en tout cas physiquement il a un
petit peu rassuré c'est une recrue très
intéressante et c'est aussi un joueur
d'auxerre on l'a bien vu à la coupe du
monde dans le vestiaire dans la vie de
groupe c'est un joueur qui apporte qui
apporte beaucoup et trop à risque d'en
avoir besoin cette saison sauf un début
de saison assez assez compliqué trois
matches sans victoire dont deux défaites
je crois il risque d'en avoir besoin
d'un joueur comme ça comme adil rami
dans cette dans cette saison à voir donc
pour trois effectivement ce qu'ils
équipent ce qui peut se passer si ça va
bien se passer pour lui qui va pouvoir
enchaîner les matches et s'en sortir on
peut passer peut-être à lyon lyon qui a
recruté alors lyon qui est un peu en
sait pas très bien ce qui va se passer
avec le local oussama voir moi j'ai
l'impression que ça voir ça fait deux
ans qui doit partir voilà peu frais vous
savoir savait donc besoin qui doit
partir et ne part pas comment
l'expliquer alors l'année dernière on se
rappelle qu'il avait quasiment quitter
lyon pour pour la juventus en tout cas
la juventus était très très très très en
avance sur ce sur ce dossier finalement
il est resté à lyon il retrouve là entre
guillemets sous la contrainte et en même
temps il n'est pas non plus malheureux à
lyon c'est quand même son club formateur
c'est chez lui
maintenant la vue en ce début de saison
où il a été assez assez irrégulier même
au cours de ces matchs où on l'a vu
parfois montré quelques signes
d'agacement lorsque dans le jeu ça
n'allait pas son départ il est il est
tout à fait possible d'ailleurs lyon se
serait même d'après l'équipe se serait
déjà activé pour le remplacer si besoin
avec benjamin bourigeaud de rennes où
c'est de m'avoir c'est peut-être le
moment pour lui en tout cas d'aller voir
aller à l'étranger maintenant reste à
savoir où arsenal serait plutôt
intéressé lensois étaient intéressés
l'année dernière était toujours là cet
été maintenant tottenham a l'air d'avoir
pris la main c'est peut-être le bon
moment pour aussi m'avoir pour pour les
voir l'étranger les vins étrangers pour
voir respectivement sylla le ciel
potentiel au final de jouer dans un
grand club
comme tottenham ya eu aussi une arrivée
qui étaient assez importantes pour lyon
c'est celle de shaqiri qui fait figure
de recrue phare de l'été on peut le dire
zeghdane shaqiri qui est toujours très
très bon quand il avec la suisse ouais
mais qui en club joue à liverpool depuis
un moment et ne joue pas beaucoup mais
voilà ils sortent de je crois à trois
saisons à liverpool où il a assez peu
joué il n'a jamais réussi à s'imposer
n'a jamais réussi à assumer ce statut
qu'il avait acquis notamment avec
l'équipe de suisse on l'a vu à l'euro
pour qui on l'a très bien vu face à la
france où il resta vraiment un leader un
milieu offensif percutant
dangereux de loin sur ces frappes
c'est un joueur vraiment qui montre de
l'irrégularité est ce qu a lyon il peut
s'imposer ce qui peut trouver son rythme
en tout cas s'il ya départ du sénat voir
on peut se dire qu'il aura un petit peu
de place peut-être un petit peu les clés
de la tacc pitard bosch en tout cas
l'air assez content de lui il a parlé de
lui comme d'un joueur intelligent on le
sait en plus speed 1 bosch a pas mal
tiré sur son effectif sans s'en cacher
qu'il voulait des recrues là il en a une
il a l'air plutôt content de l'avoir
maintenant on verra si chacun y arrive à
s'adapter à lyon on a fait le parallèle
avec shaqiri sûr dans notre joueur a ses
petits qui était qui a été relancé à
lyon mathieu valbuena est ce que ce
parallèle et on dira correct
oui correct je sais pas alors mathieu
valbuena pour le coup il arrivait dans
un contexte dans un contexte pardon très
très différents se rappelle puisqu'il
avait longtemps joué à l'om donc à lyon
ils n'étaient pas forcément très
apprécié en plus on se rappelle qu'il
avait de guerre entre guillemets en tout
cas juridique avec karim benzema karim
benzema qui est l'idole absolue à lyon
donc c'était difficile pour lui de se
faire vraiment adoptés on se rappelle
quand il était retourné au vélodrome ils
avaient été la cible des sifflets de
l'om des sifflets des supporters de l'om
pardon
qui avait même érigé des je crois une
poupée à son effigie pour pour le
provoquer pour le faire sortir de son
match il était dans un autre contexte
c'est il n'y a pas vraiment performer à
lyon je pas sûr qu'on puisse vraiment
les comparer je passe sur ce soit
exactement le même style de jeu
mais je pense que chaque errant tout cas
c'est un pari intéressant pour pour l'ol
il sort deux saisons galères à liverpool
il est bien en suisse c'est peut-être le
moment pour lui un petit peu de
s'affirmer dans un club où le contexte
médiatique en tout cas sera un peu plus
léger qu'à liverpool alors une question
en forme de blague de la part d' arnaud
coudry qui lui demandait ce qu'il aime
appeler peut signer à toulon et colby au
psg je répondrais juste que si la
l'actualité readers rugby vous intéresse
vous allez voir sur le site du figaro en
sport chelsea colby qui devrait aller de
toulouse à toulon c'est un article du
figaro vous n'hésitez pas à aller le
voir on nous demande on doit peut-être
en reparler un peu
parlons de mvp on a encore beaucoup de
supporters madrilènes dans le chat qui
demande à perez de sortir le chèque pour
elle battait pour neymar pardon il
demande aussi de sortir à chaque tournée
alors neymar normalement il devrait pas
bouger non c'est pas faux
autant les autres années normalement il
bougeait la série reste un bébé on peut
peut-être juste en reparler rapidement
mba pays devrait il devrait il pourrait
partir à madrid
les voyants s'allument petit à petit
pour un départ ouais les voyants
s'allument petit à petit ça un peu c'est
une très bonne métaphore pour le coup on
l'a dit tout à l'heure le psg le real
madrid semble jouer cartes sur table qui
les amap est aussi bape et veut aller au
real madrid est-ce que ça se fera cet
été ou l'année prochaine ça on ne sait
pas mais ça sent quasiment acté quinze
jours qu'il ya un bape et portera le
maillot du real madrid en tout cas c'est
son choix depuis toujours et c'est le
soin depuis toujours du real madrid le
real ne se cache plus le real veut qu'il
y ait la paix le real a fait une offre
et la laisser fuiter leonardo a réagi a
surenchéri il n'a pas caché que tu
n'aimes pas belle veut s'en aller et l'a
maintenu que le psg veut garder killian
bape et risques pgr vraiment garder qu
il m appelle cet été ou veux juste faire
encore monter les enchères pour jouer
entre guillemets ce jeu de poker menteur
avec le real madrid est ce que le psg
est résigné c'est très difficile à dire
ce qui parle est certain c'est que
client m'appelle jouera au real madrid
et que ça se fera cet été ou non ça ne
peut pas le dire ce qui se passera dans
les prochains jours on ne sait pas mais
sur ce qui se passera dans un an tout
cas et / ou sera quilliam ap le 1er
septembre 2022 donc pour le coup ça on a
une idée pour le coup je crois qu'on
voit un petit pas les grandes voix là
alors je
vous préviens effectivement ce visuel
n'est pas officiel absolument pas c'est
que peut-être qu'elle m'avait aller à
vallabrix et du coup on vous a fait ce
petit visuel est à dire tu as dit en
tout cas d'être intéressant c'est
ils ont laissé fuiter l'offre madrid
effectivement quand on quand un club
fait des tractations général c'était
assez c'est assez secret là toute la
presse en a parlé tout d'un coup ça fait
partie du jeu du poker de florentino
perez oui totalement c'est une façon de
mettre la pression sur sur le psg et
d'attendre justement un peu le dernier
moment pour pour mettre le psg dans le
mur pour se dire d'accord qu'est ce
qu'on fait et ce qu'on le gadel ce qu'on
vend maintenant parce qu'après dans un
an on ne pourra plus le vendre il
partira librement c'est évidemment la
hantise de tous les clubs quand un
joueur est en fin de contrat et pg pour
le coup n'y échappe pas vraiment même si
leonardo justement mais ça on avant dix
ans que le pg que le psg que le départ
de clients bape et s'il doit se faire se
fera sous les conditions du psg
ça malheureusement c'est pas forcément
certains parce que au final qui abat
paix s'il ne prolonge pas il peut tout à
fait partir libre donc maintenant le
real madrid joue un petit peu jouer un
petit peu son jeu en mettant la pression
sur le psg leonardo a répondu il a remis
la pression sur qui la map est sur le
real madrid surtout si on ne bat p en
dix ans comme la paix avait promis qu'il
allait quitter le pays que s'il allait
quitter le psg ça ne serait pas lieu
donc maintenant si la map et ne prolonge
pas et si le psg refusé des offres bas
qu'il aime bape et il sera il serait
bien embêté il sera bloqué il pourra pas
honorer sa voisine imagine aussi pour
lui dans sa communication c'est quand
même dur de rompre sa et de dire voilà
moi je voulais faire monter paris et au
final le jeu les laisse tomber entre
guillemets sa communication elle en a
pris un coup dur avec l'arrivée de
lionel messi lorsqu'elle nasser
al-khelaifi on a en a parlé en
conférence de presse lors de la
présentation de 2006 lorsqu'il a dit bah
pays n'a plus d'excusé à plus d' excuse
pour ne pas prolonger puisque il
demandait des garanties sportives là
effectivement avec sergio ramos lionel
messi est tout ce qu on a vu les
garanties sportives sont elles sont
présentes dans un landau solide a priori
leonardo a réitéré sa en disant que
qu'il y ait la paix était au centre du
projet mais qui n'était pas au dessus du
projet maintenant effectivement mbappé
il est un petit peu coincés et ils ne
communiquent plus trop sur le sujet
parce que peut-être que son argument de
projet sportif n'était pas vraiment ce
qu'il pensait que c'était juste qu'il
voulait quitter le real madrid et se
trouvait un peu une raison maintenant il
est embêté parce qu'il peut
difficilement dire que le projet sportif
lui convient pas il sait que c'est
compliqué en plus à 600 x avait déjà été
fait de base de partir au real madrid
c'est con mais aussi de repartir dans
l'autre sens on va là
alors là une question de valeurs renault
scénic reichenberg excusez-moi si le nom
est mal épelé qui ne savent pas se dire
ex moi qui suis un grand fan du figaro
j'aime cette diversité dans le contenu
eh bien merci à toi de de commenter cela
on pourra d'autres lives foot on vous en
parlera un peu à la fin mais en tout cas
demain il y aura un tirage au sort de la
ligue des champions et vous pourrez
vivre avec nous
ils nous d'ailleurs il nous pose une
question en soit si hazard était décisif
on n'aurait pas eu besoin de réclamer
aim map et vinicius assure quand même
oui mais vinicius est ce que c'est le
même calibre
vinicius c'est un joueur c'est un genre
que j'aime bien mais je pense que l'on
peut absolument pas le comparer
aujourd'hui akiyama paix c'est un joueur
extrêmement irrégulier qu'absolument en
pas le sens du but la technique la tient
en fait pas grand chose pas grand chose
qui se rapproche de ma paie finalement
en tout cas dans dans le niveau de son
jeu de ses qualités je suis pas sûr que
vinicius puisse être vraiment comparer à
ma paie aujourd'hui effectivement eden
hazard c'est vrai que ça a été un vrai
flop au real madrid c'était l'un des
meilleurs joueurs du monde à l'époque à
chelsea un vrai prétendant au ballon
d'or
au real il n'a jamais trouvé son rythme
et il a eu des blessures aussi l'udc ils
ont pas mal handicapés il a jamais
répondu aux attentes aujourd'hui on voit
mal eden hazard retrouvé son meilleur
niveau
effectivement si ces joueurs là avait
comment dire avaient atteint leurs
potentiels avaient atteint leur meilleur
niveau peut-être qu'on verrait les
choses différemment c'est aussi le cas
de vinicius c'est vrai qu'il avait un
vrai potentiel maintenant on voit sur
deux trois saisons qu'il n'assume pas du
tout peut-être qu'il arrivera à maturité
plus tard mais aujourd'hui oui le real
madrid aurait bien besoin d'un dac
synamap est en tout cas pour redevenir
un grand club prétendant à la ligue a et
à la ligue des champions mais surtout
qu'on l'a dit en plus le recrutement du
real madrid cette saison c'est david
alaba c'est ça c'est extrêmement c'est
extrêmement léger l'oréal déjà je crois
à l'été 2010 qu'il n'avait pas du tout
recruter
effectivement il se ménage beaucoup là
dessus alors il repose encore sur des
cadres c'est benzema qui a récemment
prolongé lucas modric toni kroos
casimiro ce milieu de terrain qui avait
gagné 3 ligue des champions de suite qui
est toujours présent
effectivement david alaba qui est venu
un peu renforcé cet effectif mais c'est
vrai que le real joue un petit peu à
l'économie et c'est aussi ça qui leur
permet d'être assez fort finalement sur
ce dossier qu'il ya ma paix parce qu'en
terme de manne financière ils sont assez
large offre de 160 millions d'euros pour
une seule année de contrat ça ne leur
fait plus peur aujourd'hui
effectivement on a on peut parler aussi
des défenseurs français en angleterre
enfin surtout d'un défenseur français en
angleterre c'est kurt zouma qui joue à
chelsea qui devrait normalement bouger à
west ham et cela et ça pourrait faire un
effet domino c'est ça dont kurt zouma
qui est un petit peu qui n'est pas
vraiment dans les petits papiers de
thomas stovell en tout cas à chelsea qui
pourrait donc rester à londres en allant
à west ham et ce qui se passerait sait
que chelsea pourrait enfin se lancer à
l'eau se jeter à l'eau dans le dossier
je le kundé à séville on en parlait déjà
il ya un petit mois on va dire ou à ce
moment là on parlait peut-être même d'un
échange 15 ou mal je le kundé ça sera
pas sous cette forme là mais couderc il
a été international français cette année
il est indiscutable à sévir il a montré
qu'il était un des tous meilleurs
défenseurs du championnat espagnol
effectivement de chelsea aimerait bien
se renforcer avec lui on parle d'une
hausse de 5 ans 60 millions d'euros ça
pourrait ne jouer en tout cas dans les
derniers jours du mercato effectivement
va y avoir cet effet domino entre deux
défenseurs français a priori le départ
de zuma peut libérer la place à jules
goda cetin gens que je lui connais sort
d'une très bonne saison a sévi il en
sort comme un top défenseur ça pourrait
être un bon coup pour tel seuil et
surtout pour pour thomas schoorel oui
pour thomas sowell et j'ai même envie de
dire intéressant et je dirais
intéressant en tout cas pour pur jus
condé alors serre est peut-être un petit
peu vivre parce qu'il est parti de
bordeaux il n'y a pas très longtemps
tout s'est accéléré pour lui d'ailleurs
on a vu qu'il a eu un numéro assez
compliqué alors il n'a pas toujours joué
à son poste il a été un peu par le
ballet entre la défense centrale le
couloir droit ça a été un petit peu
compliqué pour bien digérer il faut pas
non plus peut-être que tout est tout
aille trop vite mais à chelsea il
rejoindrait le tenant du titre de la
ligue des champions un prétendant au
titre en angleterre ça serait aussi très
intéressant je pense quand je le connais
on à olivier qui revient un peu sur le
sur le dossier m pap et qui nous demande
qui va le remplacer au psg on a un peu
répondu ça tout à l'heure est ce qu'on a
besoin de remplacer m a pris au piège
des salles actuelles la question c'est
presque est-ce que keegan bape et sera
remplacé en fait on a parlé notamment de
gronaldo on a dit que peut-être le psg
pourrait faire entre guillemets un
caprice en disant bas puisqu'on perd
mbappé on va faire un autre gros coup on
va recruter ronaldo et on va car jouer
avec messi effectivement médiatiquement
ça serait incroyable est-ce que
sportivement ça serait la meilleure
alternative
financièrement aussi est-ce que ça
serait la meilleure solution ça on peut
se poser la question parce qu'on a le
dos et un problème surtout financier
pour la juventus plus que sportive
finalement est-ce que kilian maps et
sera remplacé ça parle aussi de quelques
petits joueurs en tout cas pour
renforcer un petit peu la tacc pour
renforcer le banc plutôt est ce que qui
aime apple a besoin d'être remplacés je
ne suis pas sûr je pas sûr que ça en
prendra la direction si jamais il s'en
va il ya d'autres postes que le psg
pensait aussi renforcé on a parlé des
doigts dans d'eduardo qu'est mavinga
tout à l'heure on n'a pas parlé de paul
pogba mais qui a aussi toujours toujours
des rumeurs il a toujours pas prolongé
non plus à manchester united on parlait
aussi du poste de latéral gauche on en
parlait la semaine dernière lors de
l'arrivée de 2006 on parle notamment de
théo irlandaise
est ce que le psg va se renforcer encore
dans cette fin de mercato c'est une
vague possibilité surtout avec le départ
de clients de la paix mettait pas en
attaque surtout que là l'équipe du psg
c'est vraiment une équipe all stars on
peut dire elle vraiment c'est
impressionnant il ya ce poste de latéral
gauche effectivement où on à ron bernad
ce qui est blessé très souvent est
derrière et
encore si jamais il reste au pg parce
qu'ils ont été annoncés sur le sur le
départ effectivement le poste de latéral
gauche c'est peut-être celui qui
représente une petite faiblesse avant il
y avait aussi le poste de latéral droit
le pgr a très bien remédier avec achraf
à kimi est ce que le psg va jeter sur un
intérêt de gauche en tout cas ça parle
beaucoup de de terrain anglaise sans
parler un petit peu moins quand même ces
derniers temps c'est en parler pas mal
il ya deux trois mois
c'est peut-être le poste que le psg doit
renforcer si jamais il fallait encore
injecté de l'argent maintenant je pense
que le psg se contenterait aussi de
garder qu'il ya la paix et le prolonger
dans un monde idéal mais ça n'en prendra
pas forcément la direction n'hésitez pas
à continuer à poser vos questions on va
y répondre
daniel enggist de 60 millions le real
madrid a montré m bape est un très grand
intérêt je pense qu'avec ça il ils ont
conquis est-ce qu'ils avaient besoin
parce qu est-ce que madrid est ce que
madrid avait besoin de cette offre pour
essayer de gagner le coeur de kiev des
faut quand même rappeler que c'est aussi
son club préféré à kiel oui c'est son
club préféré c'est je sais plus je
voyais quelqu'un dire sur sur twitter je
me souviens plus de qui qui disait que
le client mbappé en fait dans son cahier
de brouillon en cinquième il a noté
jouer pour le real madrid plus tard
c'est vraiment son rêve il s'en est
jamais caché depuis qu'il est à monaco
il a toujours été courtisé par le real
aujourd'hui ça semble venir ça ça semble
être le bon moment pour lui pour
rejoindre le real madrid en tout cas cet
été ou l'été prochain mais ça semble
sans totalement d'actualité est ce que
le real madrid a besoin de faire cette
offre pour montrer à ma paix qui le veut
je sais pas je pense que dans tous les
cas si le bape et veut jouer au real
madrid il trouvera un arrangement et je
suis pas sûr qu'il se voit vraiment
laissé tomber le real madrid pour pour
jour même au psg même là où il se sent
très bien sportivement ou une c'est
qu'il est une star qu'il est apprécié
des joueurs du vestiaire de l'entraîneur
de tout le monde je pense que s'il veut
jouer au real madrid il y jouera et le
real madrid je pas sûr qu'ils aient
besoin de faire cette offre mais c'est
aussi une manière de mettre la pression
je pense aussi sur sur le pays on a une
remarque de le punir qui me dit le psg
va accepter seulement à 200 millions ce
qui est très probable c'est que les
enchères montent petit à petit pour une
semaine oui tout à fait et c'est aussi
leonardo qui est là dessus qui a été
assez intéressant à ces mêmes
transparent qui disait que le real
madrid allait donc c'est cet autre il
n'a reconnaissait et il disait que en
gros le real madrid avait fait il faut
une fausse offre que leurs âmes que le
real avait fait une offre qui savait
qu'elle est refusée en mettant justement
la pression sur le psg et sur le pape et
pour que le bape et se disent ah donc
vous refusé de me laisser partir alors
que vous voyez bien que j'ai envie de
partir pour justement faire monter un
petit peu la température et accentuer la
pression sur le psg
maintenant le real madrid il paraît
quand même en position de force dans ce
dossier en tout cas peut-être pas à
court terme parce que s'ils pg de garder
une batte et ils le gardent mais à long
terme le psg paraît perdant si jamais
une vente amap est donc le real est un
petit peu un petit peu dans son fauteuil
finalement les bras croisés à attendre
que les choses se fassent et que le pg
se décide à prendre une décision dans le
canapé donc effectivement on va attendre
on verra un peu ce qui se passe au le
lot au concours cette semaine jusqu'à
mardi prochain vous rappelle que le
mercato se termine mardi prochain à
minuit et du coup ça devrait beaucoup
bouger d'ici deux semaines comme
d'habitude c'est toujours le grand rush
de la fin et ça part un peu dans tous
les sens
on a parlé du coût des défenseurs
français de coeur zuma de jules kundé il
ya samuel umtiti qu'il semblerait il va
rester au fc barcelone lui qui est
annoncé sur le départ depuis très
longtemps oui ça a été un grand
feuilleton là aussi on l'a souvent
annoncé sur le sur le départ en tout cas
c'est surtout le barça qui voulaient
fait se débarrasser d'une petite iq
comme de beaucoup d'autres joueurs pour
se décharger de son salaire et aussi
parce que sportivement il ne jugeait
plus que son apport était suffisant la
presse catalane a même évoqué une
possible rupture unilatérale de son
contrat en tout cas que c'est ce que
menacer le barça enverront petit é
finalement ça ne se fera pas parce que
le barça redoutent des complications
judiciaires ils ont déjà connu ça avec
un autre joueur je crois au début au
début au début de l'été où ils savent
que c'est ils vont pas y gagner en
allant jusque là maintenant finalement
il met un petit peu d'eau dans leur vin
ils se disent que finalement si on
titille reste
bon finalement il peut peut-être encore
apporté en tout cas physiquement il
commet c'est un petit peu à la retrouver
de la régularité ils passent plus il
passe plus avant il jouait il jouait
deux matchs y retourner à chaque fois
l'infirmerie maintenant j'arrive un
petit peu enchaîné à quel niveau ça
c'est encore discutable
maintenant c'est aussi le le problème de
trouver une porte de sortie aux petits
tickets un gros salaire qui a aussi des
prétentions sportives qui veut jouer
dans un club d'un bon niveau il ya quand
même du barça maintenant ça a été
difficile de trouver une porte de sortie
maintenant au barça il va rester ce
qu'il va jouer ça c'est beaucoup moins
certains d'entre nous se rappelle
effectivement de la coupe du monde 2018
où il avait été il avait été un pilier à
côté de raphaël varane et depuis il a
complètement disparu un peu à l'image de
d'adil rami alors pas dans les mêmes
proportions on va dire mais
effectivement il a quand même
complètement disparu de la circulation
on avait une question de michael qui
nous demandent comment on chez audi va
te faire pour intégrer mba paix au
système de jeu du real avec cross et
benzema alors déjà quand même rester
prudent là-dessus il n'y a pas si le
bape et va rejoindre cet été on ne sait
pas si carlo ancelotti sera l'entraîneur
du real dans un an parce que l'on sait
que tout va très vite au real madrid
maintenant effectivement mbappé benzema
on sait que c'est une association qui
fait un petit peu un petit peu rêver sur
sur le papier on a vu avec l'équipe de
france c'est le joueur qui ont une
connexion technique qui paraît naturel
parce qu'ils sont d'un top niveau et et
parce qu'on sent qu'ils peuvent
s'entendre naturellement en tout cas en
dehors du terrain comme comme sur le
terrain ça peut venir naturellement
maintenant est ce que ce sont deux
joueurs vraiment si complémentaires si
on parle je sens tout cas de benzema
mbappé on peut se poser la question
naturellement on aurait envie de
répondre que oui comme bafé est un
joueur rapide qui peut prendre la
profondeur comme benzema c'est un numéro
9 mais qui joue comme un numéro 10 que
c'est un joueur qui peut jouer en
retrait qui peut avoir une connexion
technique avec beaucoup de joueurs dans
le coeur du jeu que ça peut marcher avec
bape et qu'effectivement pour nous c'est
très intéressant de mentionner un joueur
comme toni kroos mais on peut aussi
mentionner lucas modric qui ont qui sont
des joueurs avec une grande vista avec
une grande qualité de distribution qui
pourrait servir servir de bab et qui
peut profiter déjà de sa opg avec des
neymar des vers à ti je pense que le
bape et s'adapterait assez facilement
quand même au real madrid que le jeu que
le jeu lui correspondait assez
naturellement quoi qu'il arrive c'est un
top joueur trouvé sa place au real
madrid trouver sa place pour carlo
ancelotti je pense pas que ça sera un
casse tête insoluble on va prendre
encore quelques questions on à thibault
qui nous demande on va refaire un petit
point du coup sûr le dossier de l'or le
dossier de l'or en 10 de leur attaquant
de montpellier qui devraient normalement
quitter
montpellier il devrait avoir joué son
dernier match le week-end dernier on a
vu des images où est ce qu'il pourrait
aller alors est ce que pour aller à
priori il prend plutôt la direction de
l'ogcnice en tout cas les dernières
informations évoquaient une offre
acceptée par montpellier de 10 millions
d'euros maintenant on l'a vu depuis un
ou deux jours l'olympique de marseille
s'immisce un peu dans le dossier au
dernier moment pour essayer de devancer
l'ogcnice on a vu que notamment olivier
dall'oglio entraîneur de montpellier et
président de montpellier laurent
nicollin sont sortis de leur réserve et
n'ont pas été très tendre avec l'ogcnice
et leurs façons de faire en arrivant au
tout dernier moment du mercato
est ce qu'il y a moyen de chiper
finalement andy delort sous net de gc
nice ça paraît quand même compliqué
andy delort a l'air d'avoir en tout cas
acté son départ de montpellier pour nice
en tout cas c'est sûr qu'en dit de l'or
on ne verra pas on ne le reverra pas
sous le maillot de montpellier le 1er
septembre 2021 vu les larmes qui ont
coulé lors de son dernier match le
week-end dernier ça semble très peu
probable d'autant que à marseille
au final il n'y a que deux ans vrai
attaquant de
pointe il ya mellick et après il n'y a
pas grand moulin il faut aller au bout
d'un match vous vous avec payet en
paillettes en attaquant de pointe il
aurait une place alors qu'à nice il ya
quand même de la dahlberg oui tout à
fait c'est vrai que nice il ya eu un
recrutement très ambitieux on se
rappelle avec avec dahlberg kluivert
pour pour ne citer qu'eux et on pourrait
en citer beaucoup il est finalement
christophe galtier entraîneur le
champion de france en titre
effectivement à l'om ça paraîtrait
peut-être un petit peu plus naturel
maintenant ça demanderait peut-être
aussi un système différent est ce que
mme ilic ou de l'or vont s'asseoir sur
le banc et vont être des remplaçants
régulier ça paraît peu probable andy
delort c'est un joueur qui est toujours
là facilement à 15 buts 8 passes
décisives en ligue 1 par saison tout cas
c'est un joueur qui a le niveau pour ça
ça paraît difficilement imaginable qui
rejoignent finalement l'olympique de
marseille si c'est pour être sur le banc
effectivement munich va revenir de
blessure il avait quand même été assez
convaincant sur sa seconde partie de
saison je crois qu'il termine la saison
même sur un triplé
ça paraît difficile d'imaginer en tout
cas un des deux joueurs qui doit être
titulaire et l'autre remplaçant à l'om
peut-être qu'à nice en tout cas si
galtier le désire vraiment on peut se
dire que l'andi de l'or se laissera
convaincre très bien on va prendre des
dernières questions alors on allait
alors on à la citation exacte de
leonardo sur la map et pour nous on est
clair on le garde et on le prolonge oui
on doit pas laisser partir pour une
somme inférieure à ce qu'on a payé donc
on doit encore des sous à monaco j'avais
pas vu qu'il avait dit sa part concédé
face à la menthe wade avait dit farès
qui est ce qu'il dit ce qu'il a dit
c'est que ils veulent ils veulent
laisser partir mais bien à leurs
conditions mba paix au real ce serait
une bonne nouvelle pour l'équipe de
france complémentarité avec karim
benzema au niveau du jeu c'est que ça
c'est toujours utile oui effectivement
des joueurs qui jouent qui joue en club
ensemble et qui se retrouve en sélection
généralement c'est plutôt une bonne
chose en tout cas ça permet de se se
connaître et de développer une relation
technique sur le terrain plus facilement
ça a été notamment des sujets avec le
retour de karim ezzehard une équipe de
france qui retrouvait qui retrouvait ou
découvrait certains coéquipiers pour le
coup il découvrait qu'il ya ma paie donc
ça demande une adaptation express en
équipe nationale on a très très peu de
temps effectivement ça pourrait être une
bonne nouvelle pour l'équipe de france
de ce point de vue là maintenant je
pense que l'équipe de france aujourd'hui
elle a un petit peu le temps aussi la
prochaine échéance la grande échéance en
tout cas c'est le mondial 2022 c'est
dans un an et quelques dans un an et à
l'e3 quatre mois je pense que l'équipe
de france a le temps et je suis pas sûr
que l'équipe de france est absolument
besoin en tout cas que le quidam bape et
rejoindre le real mais le real madrid
l'a maintenant je pense pas que ça fera
d'énormes différences
alors si on n'a pas d'autres questions
je continue de regarder mais donc si
vous avez encore des questions n'hésitez
pas à les poser bah sinon on va terminer
ce live on va vous donner rendez vous
demain puisque de maria le tirage au
sort de la ligue des champions avec deux
peut-être trois clubs si monaco arrive à
se qualifier mais pas super bien parti
mais il ya du suspense en frappant ce
soir il y aura du suspense pour ce soir
voilà il y aura un tirage au sort de la
ligue des champions demain à partir de
18 heures ou le frappeur livre et la
semaine prochaine à mardi vu que ce sera
la fin du mercato vous fera un live
aussi à cette heure-là à 17 heures je
vous remercie d'avoir été nombreux à
nous poser des questions et à avoir
suivi ce live merci sébastien d'avoir
été présent la merci et on vous dit à
bientôt sur figaro live